welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
this is my very first episode and I'm
really excited to get this podcast
started special thanks to Eric from up
fire digital who's been absolutely
instrumental in getting this off the
ground I'm hoping I can provide you with
honest conversations about topics that
are generally avoided I'm aiming to stay
truthful and I'm thrilled to have the
opportunity to speak with incredible
individuals this episode I talked to
Aubree Marcus Aubree Marcus is the
founder and CEO of on it a lifestyle
brand based on a holistic health of
philosophy he calls total human
optimization he's also the host of the
Aubrey Marcus podcast and is the New
York Times bestselling author of own the
day own your life Aubrey gets some hate
sometimes for being a snake oil salesman
and I think the people who hate him are
probably the people who need to listen
to what he says the most just like the
people who hate me need my diet the most
thought I'd throw that in there so I can
tease my audience right off the bat
Aubrey and I discussed topics ranging
from polyamory to psychedelic compounds
and his recent major relationship change
I hope you enjoy this episode and
remember to subscribe if you want to
hear more
[Music]
Bree welcome to my podcast thanks for
joining me of course
good to be here I think we met the first
time a couple of years ago at paleo
effects we were on a panel about
something about the differences between
men and women remember you and I yeah
yeah that was so I think that was 2018
anyway so I assume amost of my audience
probably knows who you are but I wanted
to start if you could just give a brief
background about who you are and then I
have a whole bunch of questions mainly
to ask you how you kind of live as a
fairly successful person yeah I mean
obviously it's a little bit easier to
say what I've done than Who I am that's
a complicated question but I founded a
company called on it and that's focused
on total human optimization supplements
foods fitness equipment wrote a
best-selling book called on the day on
your life I have a podcast called Audrey
Marx podcasts and yeah just trying to do
my best to learn and share that
knowledge with as many people who care
to listen okay well I think the main
people who listen to my podcast are
people who I think have gone through
quite a bit especially on the health
front because I'm you know into the
carnivore diet trying to figure out how
to optimize people to but in a fairly
dramatic dietary way so I thought one of
the things I know that you went through
is I if you don't mind talking about it
is I know you were in a pretty intense
accident a number of years ago and
because a lot of my audience have been
through traumatic experiences I'm just
like gonna get into it I'm wondering if
you have ways to deal with trauma or how
you tried to stay positive throughout
your experience it was really
interesting so let me tell people what
happened so it was the middle of the day
I got a good night's sleep I woke up I
was getting ready for podcasts it's one
of my favorite musicians his name's
knock oh never done a podcast with him
before excited to go to my office and
jump in the studio grabbed a sparkling
water from the fridge
put it in my cup holder I remember
leaving the gate at my my property and
then next thing I know I was hearing the
jaws of life cut me out of the car so I
just my brain just shut down and it's
never happened to me before I'm not like
somebody who faints you know I've even
been a boxer and you know trained mixed
martial arts and I've gotten hit pretty
hard and I still haven't like gone out
and you know that but that was many
years ago so all of the real logical
reasons why this happened don't really
make sense you know there was no you
know head trauma there was no no other
issues but for whatever reason my
consciousness just blinked out and so I
crashed into a guardrail I was in the
Tesla crashed in the guardrail guardrail
malfunctioned actually and cut through
my driver side window and then it holds
my it pulled my nose off my face and
then split me I had like 100 stitches
split me from close to my eye down all
the way through cut through my lip and
then another piece almost all the one
that almost killed me was the one that
was right here on my neck and almost
slit the veins in my neck and but
anyways since I was completely passed
out I didn't have a lot of like whiplash
rather like skeletal type of injuries
and the test was a really safe car and
that was helpful but I was a bloody mess
and absolutely bloody mess and then I
kind of was blinking in and out of
consciousness as I went you know I was
getting wheeled into the hospital and
you know they asked me to code on my
phone and who I should call and my
partner at the time his name was Whitney
and had them call her and she met me at
the hospitals that was the she was the
one who kind of let everybody know what
was going on and yeah that was that was
an interesting moment because there was
the first grief of what happened and
then really what I felt was I'm sorry
you know so I just kept saying like I'm
so sorry you know I didn't didn't mean
to do this obviously I didn't mean to
put us all through this experience
obviously saying sorry for something
there's a complete accident is also kind
of silly as well but uh but anyways that
was that first feeling but then
initially the very next feeling was the
feeling that this
happen for me not to me and I had no
idea why but I just really believed that
from from the onset and that's something
that's a mindset that I've trained
that's a mindset that I've practiced so
that was yours yes it was
it was just something that naturally
came it was deeply ingrained you know
and and I think that's something that
because I had applied that principle to
so many other things so many other
challenges that have happened in my life
that when this really big challenge
happened it was just like my default
Network you know it's like like a
fighter who's trained to move so many
times they just do it automatically or a
basketball player that's trained a
certain move or anything that's that's
happened so often that you just it's
muscle memory at that point this was
like psychic muscle memory and I was
just sure but it happened for me not to
me and that attitude just stayed with me
and that made a huge difference because
I didn't wallow in any kind of despair
or why Me's or any of those different
mental patterns and that really allowed
me to heal remarkably fast and kind of
keep my emotional state in a really good
position wow that's incredible I've seen
a lot of people who go through some
tough things so a lot like I said a lot
of people I talked to have really severe
autoimmune disorders and there I find
there are two types of people who get
those and one of them say there's
absolutely nothing I can do this is
really unfair and they turn into this
resentful mess that that's just angry
and like mean to be around and then
there's another type of person that gets
overly compassionate towards other
people because they understand what
suffering is like it's just interesting
to have different mindsets what are the
ways like is there anything you can
recommend trying to get people into that
headspace because to go through
something like horrific and then think
there's something positive I can take
out of this or this happen to me for a
reason that's that's a really healthy
place to be but that is not easy yeah I
mean I think one of the things I
recommend is if you look back if we all
look back on our own life and I'm sure
you can look back on your life you had a
lot of physical struggles that led you
to find the remedy in all of these
dietary
means so you can look back in that and
I'm sure say oh wow I'm grateful that I
had this so that I can learn how to
solve it and then share with the world
how to solve this that's exactly it yeah
and and most of us can say the same
thing anything that we've gone through
from you know my dad had a real anger
kind of issue when I was growing up and
his anger he would just surprise me with
a bunch of anger for something that I
said you know maybe two days before and
that taught me you know so yeah that was
traumatic but it taught me how to really
be very keen about what I was
communicating from an extremely early
age so like I was very in tune with them
you know my emotional intelligence about
what he was going through what how my
words could be interpreted and
misinterpreted and so it gave me a
superpower so subsequently I've healed
the trauma and now I get to keep the
superpower so literally everything from
the accident stuff that happened in
childhood to the mistakes I've made I've
always been in grateful for them with
enough time and enough hindsight so the
thing I recommend is if you look back
and realize that you're grateful for
everything in hindsight why not be
grateful for everything with foresight
so whenever anything happens maybe you
don't know why you're grateful yet but
you just know that you are and that's
what happened with me in the accident I
didn't know why yet but I knew that I
was grateful I just had to figure out
the reason why and that was because I
was using that hindsight his foresight
and I knew at some point I'd be grateful
for it I just had to wait for that time
so might as well be grateful now okay
that actually works I was I was gonna
actually I'm gonna ask anyway have you
ever done any type of personality test I
know my dad has one out but I'm
wondering if this has anything to do
with you being you know an emotionally
stable person or if this is something
that you've actually trained what do you
think you know it's uh I think I have
taken in what is the Briggs Myers or
something I he doesn't do myers-briggs
he does one it's got my big five it's
the big five aspect scale it's a it's
been a while it's been a while since
I've done it but I have done it before
I think it's a combination I'm sure I
had some natural proclivities and then I
think I've trained myself in some of
those strategies as well so you know I
think it's its use
to know what your starting point is with
your personality but also important to
know that you have the power to change
your faith you know we can literally
decide our fate with the choices that we
make yeah yeah I and I agree and like I
said I was gonna ask you about the
personality question assuming that it
might be you being low in neuroticism
but I'm really prone to being completely
stressed out and like crazily stressed
out and I've actually managed to switch
my mindset to looking back on things and
being grateful for what happened so that
I could learn so that I could help other
people so yeah I agree it's probably not
just personality and maybe it's not
personality at all maybe it's just what
you learn
okay well that's intensive but I guess I
asked for an intense story so that's
what I get started right off a lot of
girls a lot of apparently not okay
another question then I've got a whole
bunch of questions for you I've been
kind of I've managed to heal myself
enough that I can actually tolerate
taking some supplements and I was really
anti supplement for a while because
everything I was taking was just flaring
autoimmune symptoms but I've managed to
be able to take some supplements and
because I'm under a lot of stress I felt
like some of them have been helpful for
dealing with stress other than all the
natural ways you can deal with stress so
I'm wondering if you like what you use
because you have the company on it and
it produces some nootropics supplements
etc so is there anything you would
recommend people try out as a stack well
there's lots of different things and
obviously I I mean one of the jokes I
make is that I designed on it to fill my
own pantry right like everything like
that we've created has been part of a
motivation for me because it was
something that I wanted or something
that I would use so there's really
nothing that I don't take but there's
certain things that I definitely lean on
you know pretty much every day that are
really important for me and I think that
could maybe give people some insight the
things that I can really don't go
without because we have performance
supplements we have alpha brain which is
a clinically study nootropic has two
double-blind randomized clinical trials
showing up at sea for focus memory
executive function but that's a
performance supplement that's when you
want to be sharp when you want to focus
when you're doing a podcast like this
you know when you're doing something
where you want your faculties to be
fully engaged in your brain to be lit up
but it's not something that's just kind
of a daily maintenance it's really you
know it's performance so as far as like
for health in general and we have other
ones for like workout performance and
different levels of performance mood
enhancements different things but daily
I think people need to focus on minerals
you know dramatically people are under
mineralized and that's partly because
even if you are eating you know plants
that are drawing nutrients up from the
soil the soils been planted so many
times that it doesn't have as many
nutrients as you really need us most of
the salt that we have is not sea salt
it's actually just artificial salt which
is sodium chloride and iodine just
artificially bonded together not like
the ocean minerals that contain up to 84
trace minerals so we're really under
mineralized particularly when it
concerns magnesium and so we have a
product called key minerals so I take
minimum for those supplements a day it
has calcium magnesium and then a couple
of the molybdenum and boron and a couple
of other like really key minerals that
you would need iodine and then fish oil
I think that's something that's that's
great to add in we're typically
deficient in omega-3s or have too high
omega sixes from nuts and other
different cooking oils and things and
low on the omega threes particularly
like EPA which comes from krill oil
particularly so we have krill oil and we
have another product join oil so that's
kind of a daily and then from there I
really think that adaptogens are
probably the most next most important
thing for me which is just kind of
leveling everything out because we're
always kind of up and down and so those
are herbs like ashwagandha rhodiola some
of those other different herbs and we
have those sprinkled in a bunch of
different formulas from our shrimp to
export to new mood to different
different other formulas so I try to
like get a sample of of all those at any
given point and if I'm not getting
enough Sun than vitamin D
that's another big one okay and then for
the performance-enhancing ones you have
what happens if someone works as they
take those on a daily basis do they just
get drained eventually that way you only
use them periodically you could I mean
it's just there's not we haven't really
found any negative feedback loop
associated and the clinical trials had
people take them every day
for like six weeks so it's not an issue
you know if you are taking them every
day you don't need to because the
clinical trials also showed that after
the first dose there was changes in the
brain chemistry that they were able to
measure with an EEG and some devices so
you don't need to you could it's gonna
be more expensive you know it's gonna be
supplements that you're taking for
performance and if you're not performing
well maybe you just like how it feels
and that's fine you know but most of us
you probably save them for performance
and that's really the only reason it's
not because they're unhealthy or there's
a negative feedback loop where you
develop a tolerance it's just you're
hitting the nitrous but driving the
speed limit you know and that's probably
not the most effective use okay that
works and what kind of like what would
that be it's not like huperzine a
choline yeah bruising a comes from who
Perseus errata
and is who praises throughout is the
full spectrum plant it's a club moss and
it has huperzine a who presented and a
couple different other alkaloids so we
try to use the full spectrum impossible
but huperzine a is the most studied and
well known extraction from that and it's
an acetylcholine esterase inhibitor so
acetylcholine esterase is what breaks
down acetylcholine in your brain and
acetylcholine is a neurotransmitter
responsible for focus acuity mental
sharpness memory and so when you inhibit
acetylcholine esterase the thing that
breaks down acetylcholine you have more
available acetylcholine because your
body is not metabolizing it nearly as
fast not that the brains like the
stomach and metabolizes but it breaks
down different neurotransmitters and
recycles everything but this slows down
that process so you just have a surplus
of acetylcholine in your brain and then
we supplement that with alpha GPC to
make sure that
getting an alpha GPC like yeah something
I just started that I really like makes
a big difference yeah okay I haven't
tried huperzine a that's like I have
powder in my bathroom that it's gonna
happen one day but I just so yeah be
mindful with it it's it's strong and if
you take too much you'll get nauseous
you know so you have to really like
temper the dose and that's one thing
that took us a while with alpha brain is
to figuring out the right ratios of that
product so make sure that it was really
well tolerated because in some of the
early doses you know we put the
huperzine a too high and people were
it's very similar to a nicotinic
reaction so if like somebody's put in a
tobacco chew or something like that and
swallowed some tobacco like that's kind
of what it feels like when you take too
much rupees na okay okay I'm gonna try
that like I said I just started it's
been like two months when I was like oh
I I don't react to pills anymore because
I used to react to everything so that's
fantastic and now I can get Muslim beef
before I went into the carnivore diet
before I knew that diet had anything to
do with health which is a funny thing to
say but before I was aware of that I
tried going the nootropic route because
I was so used to taking medications it
was like there's got to be something I
haven't tried that will work and I was
just too ill for any of them to have any
effect um but now that I'm not poisoning
myself with foods I used to be eating I
try them out again
okay well let's segue then into what
does your diet look like like I know you
were at paleo effects but I know you're
not I mean you're certainly not
carnivore so what do you do you have any
rules or what do you eat you know
basically yeah I talked about it in my
book on the day and I really do stick to
a diet that's very similar to what's in
that book and that's basically virtually
no carbs until dinnertime so for
breakfast and for lunch it's somewhere
between keto and carnivores you know
where I'm really just stripping out all
carbohydrate if I'm going leaning
towards some more ketogenic diet then
I'll obviously you know be a little bit
lighter on the protein just to prevent
the gluconeogenesis from you know
turning protein
industries ultimately which is what the
body is capable of doing obviously it's
one of the slowest sugars you know that
you get and it's one of the reasons why
it's so productive for the body's
metabolism is fast sugars are terrible
slow sugars are typically fine but if
I'm really trying to boost up my
endogenous level of ketones then I'll
slow down on that but either way it's
either really high protein really high
fat or some combination in between for
breakfast and lunch and then for dinner
I find that you know the carbohydrates
are actually helped me relax help me
stay hydrated help me kind of wind down
so if I'm if I'm going out that night
like let's say I'm gonna be out in a at
a dinner party or a cocktail party and I
want to be awake and alert in conversing
and sharp
well then I'll not have carbs for dinner
but if I'm gonna go to sleep you know
sometime after dinner and just kind of
wine the day down then that's when I'll
have and I'll just have whatever I want
that's not you know crap food you know
it's not something that's full of a
bunch of sugar full of a bunch of fried
fats or or something like that but
that's pretty much it
and you know what I've realized is I was
eating I was eating a lot of vegetables
but I really think the the most
important part of vegetables is to
actually give you the minerals that come
from the vegetables and so what I found
is that that and there's other things in
vegetables sometimes there's enzymes and
different things but really to me I
think the most important part of
vegetables with fiber and minerals fiber
for your just digestive if you need to
push stuff through your through your
colon you know that's important for that
there's other ways to do it of course
but and some people don't need to
obviously on the carnivore diet that's a
whole different framework and you just
get used to that which i think is great
but so for what if you want fiber it has
fiber and I think the other real reason
is minerals and it's because that's what
these plants are doing they're drawing
up the minerals from the soil but if you
supplement yourself with like ocean
minerals or full spectrum minerals even
like sea salt and you're taking enough
of that I really haven't felt any
difference from kind of going a lot
lighter on the vegetables so it's not
that I don't like vegetables I do
but I'm also curious about the issue
with oxalates and how that kind of
affects the system and I'm not I'm not
convinced whether it's better to have
you know vegetables or just to boost
your minerals your mineral intake and
just how vegetables when you want
it's not like I'm avoiding them like
plague or anything but I'm not really
focusing on targeting that probably as
much as I used to okay that's
interesting I found when I first went
carnivore I was eating a lot of salt and
then I cut salt out completely so I only
did beef in water for four months and I
didn't feel it was only for a month so
that wouldn't really be long enough to
get mineral deficiencies I don't think
but I didn't feel significantly worse
but adding in extra I use element so
that's like sodium potassium magnesium
and I take those all the time and that's
helped a lot it's just easier it feels
easier I never became to fit in anything
but my life feels easier adding those in
sure yeah that makes sense yeah okay
okay one of the other things then that
I'm interested in is you talk about
you've had interesting relationships
compared to the average person in that
you've had non-monogamous relationships
which at least with people I speak with
isn't the norm so I'd like to if it's
okay get into a bit of how that came up
and what the benefits and downsides were
or how about we could start with how
that came up like what made you decide
but that was something worth trying
because because it's pretty interesting
and I haven't actually shared it but I'm
happy to share it with you and your
audience I just recently got engaged and
I'm gonna I'm gonna get married I'm
gonna get married soon and it's gonna be
in a monogamous relationship now that
said and it's phenomenal it's like it's
like literally a fairy tale like you
would think that I was a disney
propagandist if i just tried to describe
her relationship be like this guy's lost
his mind
you see you know it's it's pretty wild
that's incredible and it couldn't
possibly be happier but let's rewind a
little bit
for the previous six years I was in
polyamorous relationship where you know
and that's so how that began is I met my
ex-partner name's Whitney and I met her
and we were monogamous for two years and
after those at the end of those two
years there was a couple things that
happened one I started reading books
about our anthropological history as
human beings and tribal relating and
started to understand that monogamy
wasn't always the norm and that
sometimes there were other structures
that were available and then there was
also a philosophical understanding about
the nature of love that love shouldn't
possess or own another human and then so
I had this philosophical understanding
about love and I'll talk to you about
the differences that I see now but
philosophical understanding about love
with no experience or practice I'd never
done this before and I'm also an
incredibly honest person like I it it
revolts me to think about lying
partly because I just can't bear the
stress on myself it's not this good I'm
gonna realize yes and also so stressful
it's so stressful you know I mean I'd
love to say that I'm just such a moral
being that I would never not tell the
truth but I just know from practice and
pragmatically it's just doesn't work
with my constitution because whatever
benefit I'm trying to get from the lie
is far outweighed by the stress that it
incurs on me so it's very practical and
of course obviously there's some
morality that I've is strengthening
every day as I continue to practice it
but nonetheless that never worked so
what I wanted to do was to try something
else I didn't want to necessarily leave
my partner but things had gone stale I
was interested in other people and I
suppose that she might be interested in
other people too just because the sparks
had kind of gone out from our
relationship so I proposed it to her she
was basically I don't think so let me
think about it and so she took a few
months and she actually found somebody
that she was really attracted to and had
feelings for but recognized that she
still had feelings for me
and that kind of put a light bulb off in
her head saying like oh wow I can like
two people at the same time I can laugh
and potentially even love two people
saying
so she was like all right let's try it
and I was like great and I thought it
was gonna be really easy you know when I
was the first to get another partner and
that was really hard for her and I was
like what's wrong we agreed to this and
I look back at that I'm like you idiot
but uh but anyways you know so we went
through that and she had to deal with it
first and then she started she got her
first kind of other real lover and I
remember the first moment that happened
it was like I spent most of the day like
not knowing if I needed to vomit or cry
or like fight something or like run away
it was one of the hardest experiences of
my life having a girl that I loved
sleeping with somebody else yeah but
ultimately like there's a lot of lessons
there and a lot a lot of teachings and
as we progressed you know we really
tried everything you know we tried to
have boundaries
but the boundaries would ultimately get
relaxed or transgressed and then we
would try to you know tighten things up
and then expand things and we tried
every different framework learning the
whole time making a lot of mistakes
until I finally got to the point where I
was like I I think I've really learned
the most that I could I learned the most
about my ego about my jealousy about my
anger about my emotional processing
about the importance of communication
without projection I learned so many
things that I'm just incredibly grateful
that Whitney was willing to go through
all of that with me and also learn
herself because I think genuinely one of
the best reasons to be in a polyamorous
relationship is to learn because it's
going to teach you a ton you know
because it's going to put a universal
stressor it's a universal pressure and
that pressure is going to cause
adaptation and that adaptation is gonna
cause learning and there was also some
fun moments too but but I would say the
hard moments outweighed the fun moments
of aya by a considerable amount so if it
wasn't a practice of learning it
probably wouldn't have been worth it
but so to learn is one way and then the
other reason is if you're just not quite
sure you know whether you're gonna be
continuing with this person or not then
leaving your options open is how
because one of the things now that I'm
with the woman that I'm with now I
actually met her while I was in this
polyamorous relationship and we didn't
start any relationship but I had the
freedom to meet her to flirt with her to
go out to dinner like we got to form a
friendship and in a traditional
relationship I probably wouldn't have
even been able to form that friendship
without some questions or jealousy
depending on the construct and who it is
so it was it was ultimately helpful for
me that I had the freedom to kind of
meet people and then you know four years
later we both separated from our
partners and got together and now it's
I'm just having experienced everything
just so excited to be with her forever
oh that's really nice to hear I had like
I had a hell of a time with so my
husband we we met each other and after a
really short period of time I got
pregnant and I wanted to keep the baby
and I was like 24 so it was not ideal
for continuing romance and we ended up
separating and looking back on it it was
it was hard right and relationships are
really complicated and sticking with one
person like forever it's really
complicated and people underestimate
that but what was interesting was we
separated and it was me who wanted to
separate and he eventually got a
girlfriend and we were still like close
friends because we have a child together
and we went out for dinner and he told
me he had a girlfriend and I had this
like flood of jealousy and it was just
like I I told him she was like I what
I'm jealous like I didn't see that
coming at all and it was just like
that's so it's so silly how you can
underestimate your reactions being like
that's something I feel now when it's
yeah kind of obvious in retrospect
sometimes I don't I can't tell you how
many times I made that mistake you know
she would Whitney would ask me like are
you okay with this and I'm like yeah
sure go for it and then like midway
through her trip seeing somebody else I
would be like dying I was like I'm not
okay she's like he told me you were
gonna be okay it's like I thought I was
yeah [ __ ] 20 times that happened I
mean it's unbelievable and and I
eventually eventually slowly started to
learn but it's just hard you know those
emotions will hit you and when they hit
you though you know kind of make you
bend the knee and really have to really
have to deal with them and so but that's
what trains you trains you to know
yourself to be humble enough to be like
wow yeah maybe I don't know what I'm
talking about maybe I don't know what
I'm talking about maybe I I think I
might be okay with this but I might get
crushed you know like that would have
been the honest thing for me to say with
some more wisdom from experience like
yeah I mean I think I'll be okay if you
go spend a week with homie you know but
maybe not maybe about Thursday of that
week I'm gonna be dying you know and
that's and that would have at least been
like a little bit more truthful yeah
yeah it's hard I feel that I'd
definitely had experiences like that
where I just I don't know if it's
fooling myself or I just didn't know I
think maybe I just didn't know I don't
know that's hide okay
well then the next thing I wanted to
talk about is you talk a bit about
heading towards discomfort rather than
away from it I've heard you talk about
that I don't I think maybe in in one of
your books as well so I wanted you to
delve a bit more into that into how to
know when to confront something
difficult and how to know when it's your
intuition telling you it's a bad idea
because I certainly have not figured out
I always head into discomfort and
sometimes it's just traumatizing yeah
and it's not something that you should
do so is there anything you've learned
to avoid just traumatizing yourself if
you're heading towards and towards
discomfort you know I'm probably similar
to you and then I'll err on the side of
going for it
you know if I'm uncomfortable because
there's enough times that I've gone into
discomfort and found amazing benefit
amazing growth so you get used to that
and then discomfort becomes your guide
your guide star becomes your you know
your lighthouse where you that's where
you know to wear it ahead because you're
uncomfortable with it I think one of the
things recognized is that all discomfort
by its nature is
something of a hormetic stressor so if
you don't have time to adapt to the
discomfort and respond to the discomfort
if you don't have the physical strength
or the emotional strength if you don't
have any of that then you're not going
to be able to adapt correctly so it's
just gonna be traumatic and that applies
to the physical body like if you're
exhausted and you haven't slept well
don't do that ten-minute ice Blanche you
know like your body's not going to be
able to adapt and respond in the proper
way so it's just gonna be difficult for
your immune system or don't do that
super hard work out or don't go on that
three-hour mountain bike ride if you've
just you know you're feeling a little
under the weather like you're not gonna
be able to respond correctly so you need
to adjust you need to adapt you know are
you rested enough are you ready for
whatever challenge you're going through
and whether that's physical or emotional
and then you have to assess like is
there real danger you know like is there
actual danger is this just my fear is
this the the fiction of fear that's
playing in my mind and you know I guess
something like that would be on the
physical side let's say that said
keeping it keep the metaphor of the cold
or the practice of the cold well is
there physical danger of you getting
hypothermia you know like you need to
know that or is there physical danger of
you having shallow water blackout and
actually you know passing out in the
cold you need to assess that before you
do anything and and just know what the
kind of the limitations and the
frameworks are on that so that you're
not actually doing something that's
dangerous if the water is too cold or so
yeah just know know where the line is
between you know helpful and dangerous
and the same thing with you know a lot
of emotional situations just yeah
understand all that and I think that's
the way that you can measure it and then
the final thing is you just listen to
your gut instincts you know which I
think to me is some part of the brain
that's calculating things that are
almost infinitesimal and they're just
assessing a situation based on such a
multiplicity of factors that your brain
couldn't even track them it's almost
like savant syndrome
which is in certain cases of autism
maybe 10% of cases I think is the
the statistic that they're able to track
things in a way that the normal you know
the normal brain wouldn't be able to
track you know for anybody who's seen
yeah Rain Man that was a kind of a
Hollywood version of what savant
syndrome is but it's the ability to kind
of figure things out that the normal
logical brain couldn't and I think
that's what our instincts are doing all
the time it's tapping into our own inner
savant
that's just calculating things that are
beyond what we would normally be able to
do I like that yeah that makes so much
sense I've been to it I ignored my
intuition like forcefully ignored it I
think until I was healthier because I I
thought that if you could think things
through logically make you know lists of
pros and cons and really think about it
you could come to the right conclusion
instead of just following my instinct
because I thought well what where's the
logic behind that but I like that
explanation that maybe your instinct as
part of your brain that's looking at way
more things than you're able to
consciously that's I I'm going to use
that all right I like that a lot okay
okay
so delving into wellness I know that
you've tried you've tried a whole bunch
of things that I am going to try
eventually but I know I think you went
on a darkness retreat I don't know if
it's called a darkness retreat just like
no lights for a while so I kind of
wanted and a silence retreat right
that's the same time yeah oh my god oh
my goodness darkness complete darkness
like not even one little pinprick of
light and there's absolute black so
there's no distinguishing between open
eyes and closed eyes under any situation
or any circumstance so what was that
like and how long was well that was six
days and it was also a complete silence
and complete isolation so you know
absent of human contact absent of
there's the sound I guess of the belt
they would ring a little bell when they
would put the food outside my door so I
would know when the food was arriving
but other than that there is no sound
you know that I was I was able to hear
maybe a few birds outside the wind
that was closed or you know a few things
like that but silence darkness and
isolation and it was the most powerful
journey I have ever been on and you paid
for this I did I did I did yeah you pay
for he paid for somebody to take away oh
wow okay so what was that what was that
like what did you discover well we all
have we all have antagonistic parts of
our own mind we have the hidden parts
the hurt parts the shadow parts the the
thoughts that we don't want to think the
things that we're kind of gently running
away from by distracting ourselves with
beautiful visuals or music or things
like that but in that you know solitude
in the darkness it's just you and your
mind so you're really confronting
yourself head-on so if there's anything
that's in your psyche that you need to
face whatever monsters are lurking in
those caves you know I think Joseph
Campbell said in the cave you fear is
the treasure you seek so it's just your
opportunity to show up as the hero and
face anything that's in you no lurking
in the shadows what's hiding under the
bed of your minds you know and in that
that's a amazing experience that
illuminated so many different things and
also made me appreciate so many
different things that are going on in my
life Wow well that's brave yeah I mean I
or desperate I don't know I mean I can
you can frame it either way I mean it I
think a lot of these things I've done is
because my mind is a it's a great Ally
and a great adversary and I think both
of those things go hand in hand the
strongest minds are also sometimes the
trickiest to to grapple with so it's
been a it's been a hell of an ally and a
hell of a grappling partner for most of
my life so I have to have pretty intense
practices in order to assert my I feel
that oh man yeah it's a struggle it's
definitely been a struggle for me okay
so that was the darkness and a silence
retreat I didn't realize that was this I
guess it would be the same one I for
some reason I was picturing you go into
I don't know you go into some yurt that
has no light somehow and there are a lot
of people in there and it's dark
that was you wrote a post on Instagram
and I was like that is what a darkness
retreat is I think that was for the that
was a sweat lodge
so that was the temazcal which is
exactly that it's a hut that they
actually you know put in molten hot
rocks and then splash water over the
rocks and then you get in this really
hot like sauna steam like environment
for a couple hours and that's another
really intense experience but also great
Wow
what temperature is it in there
approximately I mean it's got to be it's
got to hit waves of at least 180
Fahrenheit I would say as I mean
sometimes it'll be probably blips that
go up to 200 I've been in some Russian
baths and some other Bono's cetera yeah
they're at that kind of 200 210 range
and that's I it rarely gets that hot but
this is also a lot longer
I mean he's usually lasts at least an
hour and a half up to three hours so if
it was yeah yeah I went to Russian banya
's and one of them got to 210 and those
wow like I'm pretty good at infrared
saunas but that is on another level it
is you have to wear those funny little
hats cuz your ears yeah your hair gets
hot I had earrings on that was a bad
idea like I had rings on I had to take
off it was like other metal on me was
yeah those are all brands okay cool
okay in that case let's uh let's delve
into your work on psychedelics because I
feel like you've done most of them so
what's the mmm let's see how do I ask
what what's been the most helpful one
for you does it yeah let's start with
that you know it just depends on it
depends on the situation circumstance
what I was going through they're all
just tools and
than if what tool you're kind of
applying you what tool you're using to
fix whatever problem or to illuminate
whatever aspect of your psyche so it's
difficult to say you know I can kind of
give a brief synopsis of some of them I
mean I started my journey twenty-one
years ago the division quest when I was
18 and took psilocybin out in the
mountains and in that experience I felt
my physical body and I was a staunch
like pretty like a little bit angry
atheist at that point because I had
rejected capital our religion because I
was like this is nonsense you know like
I shouldn't we shouldn't feel guilty
there's for being for existing and being
alive like that doesn't make sense to me
and but I didn't have any other
spiritual basis to actually know God
like it was not possible for me to
understand and feel like the concept of
God because I'd never felt it and what I
was being told from the pastor's here in
Texas was something that I couldn't
accept you know so I went in and then I
felt my body evaporate and I felt what
can only be called my soul I guess you
could call your consciousness but I felt
my soul or my consciousness exists that
unborn in the undying aspect of me and I
was like oh damn like I really got to
rethink my whole paradigm here and
understand that there is something more
than the materialist reductionist
description of a body that houses you
know your soul in its brain or something
like that like the soul is separate from
that because I just felt everything else
strip away and I felt the presence of
that and that first gave me the first
glimpse of you know what the divine you
know might might feel like what it just
completely changed my framework so that
was beautiful for that and subsequently
you know a lot of the different plants
have kind of illuminated more and more
the nature of my own soul the nature of
the divine and and that's been a
beautiful aspect of it it's you know
really hard to say which one has you
know been the most impactful I think you
know psilocybin has been which is now in
phase 3 clinical trials for the
treatment of depression and anxiety
through the Hefner Institute and getting
some great research behind it for
addiction sensation cessation and
variety of things that's been probably
the most consistent since that was where
I started and that's what I'll go back
to most of the time obviously ayahuasca
has been incredibly helpful and you know
getting me over my fear of death you
know teaching me to encounter that fear
head-on just like I was talking about in
the darkness like look at that fear
death and look at any kind of traumas
that might have had stored iboga was
amazing and kind of deconstructing my
mind and then putting it back together
and giving me like really clear insight
watch Shuma was like which comes from
the San Pedro cactus and has mescaline
is its active ingredient that was great
it connecting me with my mission and my
purpose and the earth and feeling
connected with with people all across
the board and kind of eliminating the
differentiation between you know my love
for one my love for another just
recognizing that I may have people who I
enjoy the most but everybody is worthy
of love and everybody deserves it and
that was a was a really powerful lesson
from that and that's kind of the big
ones I would say that it really impacted
me the most would be those those five
okay are there are there well you told
me but are there I've done two and I'm
planning on doing ayahuasca at some
point probably assuming I can reduce my
sensitivity to plants but are they
significantly different yeah yeah
surprisingly I mean it's um there's
certain times where one will kind of
mimic the experience of another but
they're all pretty radically different
and they all have different active you
know active compounds that are doing
different things in the brain but really
the experience of them is pretty
ineffable pretty indescribable but
they're they're pretty you know when you
take the same thing you get a pretty
much reliable it's not always the same
but it has the same signature it has the
same kind of feel and when you take
something else it has just a much
different feel particularly the ones
that I mentioned iboga mushrooms are so
Sabin I
and watch Shuma and those ones in
particular all are pretty vastly
distinct ayahuasca having DMT is the
active ingredient which really opens you
up to what feels like a different
dimensionality of consciousness and
wisdom and it's the one that's the most
supernatural and that you'll encounter
other beings and other things that
really feel like they're outside of you
know I'm open to the idea that they're
just projections of our mind but they
really feel like they're things that are
outside of your own psyche
you know psilocybin is something that's
going to just shift your perspective on
pretty much everything shift your
perspective on could be a conversation
it could be music could be you know
outdoors could be anything but it just
kind of changes the way you you see look
feel about different things what Yuma
kind of really opens your heart and your
love it's serotonergic by nature it's a
opens you up to really appreciate
everything else that's around you in a
really magnificent way and then iboga is
kind of acting on all of the different
aspects of your psyche it's one of the
most robust psychedelics and it's a
24-hour experience and it feels like
hell it's the most it's the most brutal
by far but it really it really kind of
like breaks you down to a point where
all you have is the essential truth and
there's really no wiggle room so those
are it's kind of the big four I would
say gets intense 24 hours does not sound
I mean even even shrooms it's like that
lasts forever sometimes depending on how
my feels like yeah I mean I've taken
mushrooms before and it's 30 minutes of
past and I'll somehow look at the 30
minutes
kidding me spin around the cosmos seven
tribes yeah yeah I I've had experiences
like that's quite intense okay so as a
successful person I've been I've
interviewed a number of people and I'm
trying to see if there are patterns
between people who are fairly successful
and how they live so what does your life
look like as in sleeping what's your
sleeping routine well
sleep has been a struggle for me
honestly and that's been something
that's been one of the most challenging
elements I understand the importance of
it which doesn't help you go to sleep
also because when you realize how sleep
is important to virtually every aspect
of your cognitive function to your
inflammation response to weight
management to mood I mean it's just it's
involved in virtually every different
marker that you're gonna want to look at
and then you can't sleep and you're like
oh no I'm killing myself you know like
I'm gonna be worthless tomorrow so that
certainly hasn't helped and I have a
really active mind so it's been a
struggle and when I was you know really
going through challenges I think 2017
was one of the most challenging years of
my life and I got actually habituated to
taking benzos so xanax or valium to go
to sleep god yeah so then that lasted
and that lasted until April 26th of this
year so I was really reliant on these
medications to sleep and ultimately once
I got with my fiance it was such a
loving environment and and this is kind
of a testament to the healing power of
love is she loved me I felt so loved
that I felt so I was just ready to let
go of all of so much a big portion of my
anxiety a big portion of my stress and I
was actually able even though it's not
medically recommended I just went cold
turkey after three years of habituation
and just stopped and I haven't taken one
sense and there was definitely and so
and again that's not a recommendation
I'm not saying like be like me and just
do it
it was just it was the right time and I
had the right environment and just I
will say though that you know if you can
find somebody who just loves you with
this really radical unconditional love
that's it's amazing the things that you
can do that you normally wouldn't have
thought possible and
so that was kind of a just a bit of a
side note to your question but sleep has
been a challenge but so since then you
know when it went obviously you're on
medication like that it's gonna kind of
knock you out and it was but it would
not last very long so I would sleep
maybe five six hours max and then I
pretty much couldn't fall back asleep
again
so my sleep was pretty diminished for
the last couple years but now I'm
sleeping naturally so and that took a
little while to normalize but I just try
to wind down for at least an hour
stay off screens stay off the TV it's
really actually hard for me when I watch
a movie I know it's it's quite quite
enjoyable I mean I really like watching
a movie before bed but I can't fall
asleep for another hour after I finish a
movie so I try to cut off all screens if
anything read a book or just chat or
just even just lie in bed and think and
try and just you know surrender to that
however long it takes me to fall asleep
and just enjoy it rather than being
stressed about it but trying to back my
bedtime down a little bit earlier
because when I was taking the medication
that would probably take it around one
o'clock fall asleep at 1:30 and then
wake up at 7:30 and that was that was
kind of it that seemed to fit the most
for me I didn't wasn't trying to get up
at 4:00 a.m. like Jocko
you know I was happy to I was happy to
wake up at 7:30 but but now I'm trying
to go to bed a little bit earlier and
sleep a little bit longer you know
really trying to target a target that
eight hours so if I can get that which
is almost never but but I try to get
closer I'm getting close I think I slept
7 hours and 20 minutes last night I have
to order ring which tracks my sleep so
720 is a really good night for me and so
I'm feeling great today good I got I got
an aura ring and then and then I had
like the worst stress of my entire life
for like six months and was like okay
take that off for a while start again in
like three or months yeah well I'm glad
you managed to get off with benzos with
limited issues those can be quite
intense as we found they can yeah that's
what uh they can be gnarly death
I heard that from multiple sources yes I
didn't have a I was prescribed lorazepam
for sleeping when I was like 17 and
fortunately it didn't really work like I
so I took gravel instead which is just I
think it's drama meme in the states or
something it's like benadryl and and it
was just way more effective so I used to
take that to sleep but which is less
intense than taking benzodiazepines but
yeah so I'm lucky okay so we went over
your sleep schedule which is getting
there
my sleep now it's like a real no it's a
real thing yeah yeah well that's good
that's really good and your diet and
then what about exercise cuz on it cells
are oh speaking of which thank you for
sending you sent us a kettlebell and
some stick with a giant weight again
yeah and like a number of other things
and that's been really helpful for my
dad and I took the kettlebell so I'm
using the kettlebell but thank you for
that so what do you do for exercise yeah
I mean a lot of those tools you were
talking about the steel mace the stick
with the balls yeah yeah and so that was
the way I like to Train even before on
it you know I was working out with a lot
of top athletes and we would always be
testing these unconventional methods a
lot of them would had existed for in
some cases like the steel may since the
1200s the Persian Pony wrestlers would
use it they called the de gata and it
was a training method with the clubs and
the maces and kettlebells developed in
the 1900s I think it was Russian
dockworkers that they were using his
weights and then they started throwing
around and moving with them so all of
these tools that are kind of low-tech
but like high leverage that can really
yield a dramatic result for like full
body fitness so I've really been pushing
that playing sports and staying active
kind of my whole life and so I don't
have one of those stories that's you
know that people love like I was 300
pounds and then I started working out
and then I got because I've kind of
always stuck with it you know I was a
basketball player and then in college I
was you know really
played all the sports and got more into
weightlifting and then after that got
more into martial arts and then started
just training unconventional and so I've
kind of just stayed constant with it and
no matter what I don't train every day
but I at least move every day so no
matter what I'm gonna either swim or
dance or do something or walk or go for
a jog or do something every day and then
most days you know at least four or five
days out of the week I'll get a workout
session in and I'll just kind of I've
been training for so long I'm 39 years
old now so I've been training for at
least 25 years pretty seriously so with
a lot of great coaches and obviously on
it has a bunch of different top coaches
and trainers and so I just have learned
what my body is capable of and then I'll
just listen to it and push it and
sometimes I'll do yoga sometimes we'll
do weights sometimes I'll you know play
a game but I'm I'm staying active pretty
much every day okay I started doing
functional patterns to try and
recalibrate my like hip and ankle
replaced body and and that way of physio
has been very new to me so kind of like
the idea that diet can have something to
do with health it's been new figuring
out how to move and you would assume
that someone would just naturally know
how to move but turns out they don't so
the mace has been I haven't used that
mace because it's way too heavy but
working with a mace has is just an
interesting way of working out compared
to lifting weights or something I like
it yeah okay well do I have any other
questions for you I'm really I'm really
happy that you're engaged and happy
about it that's really exciting yeah
it's really exciting I always thought I
kind of erred on the side of being stuck
to one person I was always worried I was
going to be looking for other people or
thinking you know grass is greener but
it turns out there's a lot you can do
with one person if you're really like
set on it and it's just it's really
interesting
so congratulate thank you yeah thank you
I mean I think there is I mean some
people I think the commitment is really
important and I think it's important to
commit to the right person though
because commitment for commitment sake
is just a trap it's just going to leave
you stuck in a resentful and miserable
place but if you're both Co committed
you know both who you're really
committed really willing to be humble
and vulnerable and admit your faults and
your flaws and your thoughts and
everything like that be honest not be
totally honest like radically radically
honest and at that point I think it can
be such a valuable experience and of
course I'll have more more to talk about
as this relationship advances in time
because it's still young but I can see
you know whether people believe me or
not I can see this playing out and I
just know that I'm gonna love her for
the rest of my life and she's gonna love
me for the rest of her life and just the
way that we moved through things the
amount of the work that we've done on
ourselves and we're just we're so
committed there's nothing there's
nothing that that could separate us or
split us up and I just really know that
wow I think that's a good way to end
this podcast
thanks for sharing that's really nice so
congratulations and thank you for thank
you for coming on where where can people
go to find out more about you yeah the
aubrey marcus podcast is great if you
enjoy listening to podcast and instagram
at abri Marcus or my youtube which is
slash aubrey marcus pod and and or check
out on it if you're interested in the
supplements or some of the equipment
that we talked about that's oh and nit
and yeah that's pretty much it cool Wow
thanks again well I'm sure I'll be
talking to you soon yeah absolutely
could share with you
[Music]
you
[Music]